hope he's in sacramento hi colby how are
you
i'm doing good how are you doing mr
angie better than i deserve how can
chris and i help
awesome uh i have a good question
currently i'm in my third year
of college uh graduating for uh so we've
got about a year and a half left and
currently
right now i'm on baby step one i've
already saved my thousand dollars for my
starter
emergency fund and currently throughout
life i've worked hard at
many jobs and have saved up to about 37
000 that are all in stocks
and currently have a 15 000 car loan
and was just curious for baby step two
it says pay off
all debt um but right now all of my
stocks are making more than my monthly
payment um which is curious on
what i should do and uh how do i
set up myself for success in the future
i want you to brace yourself buddy
because
you said a key phrase how do you set
yourself up for the future
which means you're gonna have to let go
of some things you've previously learned
and some things you previously thought
because what we're about to tell you is
going to be a paradigm shift it's going
to be counter to anything you've heard
and it's going to feel weird and your
brain is going to try to resist it
because it sounds so weird tell him dave
well when chris and the team here did a
study on millionaires
we studied 10 000 of them not a
single one of the 10 000 millionaires
that we studied said
i kept debt on my car and used that
payment
to put into single stocks and that
caused me to be wealthy
not a single one used leveraged car
loans to invest in stocks to become
wealthy
not one of the ten thousand
which tells me that your plan sucks
that's what the data tells me okay
and so you've gotten lucky so far so far
the stocks have gone up
but they don't always go up and you're
carrying this extra debt how are you
paying for school
um i'm blessed uh my parents are putting
me through school
great okay the good news is you've got a
great financial mind and you have the
ability to look at numbers
and that's gonna that's gonna bode well
for you if it doesn't lead you
into taking risks that you don't even
realize you're taking yeah so if i woke
up in your shoes this morning what would
i do
if i was your age knowing what i know at
60 years old
with a net worth of hundreds of millions
of dollars what i would tell you to do
is what i would do if i woke up in your
shoes
if you were my son or
dad gum my grandson or whatever i would
tell you
to pay off the car today move your
single stocks into mutual funds
and be the tortoise yes don't be the
hare yep
there it is and and and i'm gonna tell
you it's crazy colby but
if i could go back in time i'd grab me
by my hair
[Laughter]
ramsay don't go there
back in the day but literally in that
mindset of getting away from a car
payment
of staying away from this cryptocurrency
phase
uh because another phase is coming and
it's a get-rich-quick scheme
and uh dave taught me something 15 years
ago don't
get rich build wealth there's a
difference in the mindset there's a
difference in the approach
and i'm going to tell you it feels
better yeah you know there's no shortcut
to any places worth going
and very few people who get wealth
quickly keep it
it's very unusual uh so somebody hits
the lotto
the bankruptcy rate of people hit the
lotto is four-fold the national average
yeah
um people who inherit money with no
effort and have been taught no character
or work ethic
promptly lose it and uh now it doesn't
mean that everyone does that they don't
uh but i mean you can teach your kids
and they can the blessing the
inheritance can be a blessing
because they've got the character but
anytime there's quick rich
that it's uh the best way to get rich
quick is don't
get rich quick and so um that's where
all of this this where
all these these sayings come from true
principles
and so that's what we tell you to do of
course you're you're a grown person
you're going to go do what you're going
to do
but ask yourself what the 30 year old
version of you
is going to think about the 20 something
version of you when you look back
did you have a fro when i was baby dave
when you had a baby i had a can you
think about this listen i had a twa
what's that it was a teeny weeny afro oh
it was little
it was little mama hogan did it to me i
wasn't old enough i mean like like when
you're a teenager no
i don't think it was your hair no no it
was it was it was a little i just had a
little bit because you're always wearing
a football helmet well
yeah well you don't want you don't mess
it you mash it down yeah i had to i kept
it low
okay but the story behind the first
shaving of the head
we said if we made it to the national
championship game in college we were all
going to shave our heads
and i'll be doggone if we didn't make it
and so that was the first time a razor
touched my head
and i never never went back never went
back i'm like this is a little bit and
then it wasn't optional i like
this yeah that's just you it is it is it
just
can't i can't imagine that head with a
fro on it that just would be more than i
mean like the full size
no i can't you know the big ones yeah
you know like the 1970s
you remember i mean that would be that
would be that's a picture i need
no i'll i'll find one on thursdays on
whatever it is twitter
or instagram i will reach out to mama
hogan and i will get that posted on
instagram
follow me at chrishogan360 you are going
to see a small afro soon
yeah there you go there it is small one
small all right little
low yeah